-Our first guest tonight
is a musical legend,
a 20-time Grammy Award winner,
an Academy Award winner,
a Tony Award winner,
and member of both
the Songwriters Hall of Fame and
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
His new album,
"Only the Strong Survive,"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show,
The Boss,
Bruce Springsteen, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Thank you.
Glad to be here.
-Last time --
Last time I saw you was
backstage at your Broadway show,
which was fantastic.
Was that something --
Looking back at it,
can you believe now you did it?
Was that ever something you
thought you were gonna do?
-We did 236 of them,
so, uh, it took 14 months.
About five days of --
five nights a week.
And I loved every night of it,
you know?
It wasn't something
I thought I'd do
'cause it happened by accident.
You know, I was --
Two weeks before President Obama
was leaving the White House,
he asked me
to come down and play.
So I said, "Well, I don't
want to bring the band.
Too much noise."
[ Laughter ]
"I'll go down by myself
with my acoustic guitar,
and I'll read something from my
book, and I'll sing a song."
So that's -- I spent a couple
hours in my studio,
and I worked up about
90 minutes of something.
I went down, and I played
in the East Room
to just a couple hundred people.
But it was basically 90 minutes
of the Broadway play, you know?
And so he came up to me
afterwards, and he said,
"Gee, you know,
I'm glad you did that for us,
but that should be a show."
So I said, "It's good
presidential advice, you know?"
[ Laughter ]
-And is it true he takes a cut?
He took 15%?
-Unfortunately, it was true.
That's true.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know
if you remember this,
but we were lucky enough --
I brought my mom
to see the show,
and we went backstage,
and you were being very gracious
with your time.
And I was very cognizant
of the fact that
you're a busy guy,
and, wonderfully,
Patty stepped in and said,
"Before they leave, Bruce,
you got to take a picture
with Seth's mom,"
and this photo is celebrated
in our house.
[ Laughter, audience "Awws" ]
-She looks great.
-She looks wonderful.
Doesn't she look good?
-She looks fabulous.
[ Applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
-The thing -- the joke
my brother and I always say is,
we've never seen he look that
happy in a picture with our dad.
[ Laughter ]
I've never seen a photo of her
where her eyes aren't rolling.
[ Laughter ]
This is --
This album, these are,
obviously, soul songs
that mean something to you.
-Yeah. It was just a lot
of stuff that I liked.
And it was during the lockdown,
so I'd made a couple of records.
Made a record
called "Western Stars,"
and I made a film with it.
Made a record called
"Letter to You"
with The E Street Band,
and I made a film with that.
'Cause you couldn't
go out on the road.
So, still sitting there
with no schedule in front of me,
so I said, "Well, I'd like to --
Let me do something
I've never done before.
that's centered on my voice
and just singing."
The greatest vocal music,
in my opinion, of all time
is gospel music
and then soul music.
All the singers
came from the church.
So I just dug into my collection
of my favorite singers.
Jerry Butler and David Ruffin
from The Temptations,
Levi Stubbs from The Four Tops,
William Bell.
And I just started to go through
music that I found that
I had a good range for
and fit my voice pretty well.
And I made one record,
I threw it out.
And then, I finally
focused on the soul --
the idea of making
a cohesive soul-music record.
And so that's what we did.
I really -- I did it for myself.
It was a lot of fun.
I hope people enjoy it.
-You know, there's a great --
Sam Moore, from Sam & Dave,
is on a couple of the songs.
I know you've sung with him
in the past.
-Yeah.
-On stage, in concert.
You know, you've sort of given
this gift to people.
You know, you did a song
with Jack Antonov.
Obviously,
you mean a lot to him.
He gets to sing with you.
What's it like for you when
you get to sing with somebody
who obviously meant a lot to you
in your early days?
-Well, Sam & Dave were gigantic
in my musical development,
'cause what most people
don't understand,
Sam Moore
was an incredible band leader.
And I used to go see Sam & Dave
when they played
The Satellite Lounge
in Fort Dix, New Jersey,
The Fast Lane in Asbury Park.
These are 200-, 300-seat clubs.
And this was in the late '70s.
They were not --
I don't know if Sam was speaking
to Dave at the time.
They weren't getting along,
but they were still incredible,
you know?
So incredible that, one night,
I stood in the back
of a tiny club
that was only half full.
And I knew I was seeing
some of the greatest music
in the United States
that very moment.
And I just cried, you know?
That --
Just over how good they were.
Just 'cause they were so good.
And so I've known Sam
for about 30 years.
And we've sung together
on a few things.
And he's a great guy,
and probably
our greatest living
soul singer right now.
-And is it a quick "yes"
when you call up Sam and say,
"Do you want to be
on the new album?"
-Yeah, Sam's game to sing.
He still loves singing.
He's 86,
but still loves to sing.
-You can't -- You wouldn't guess
86 when you listen to it.
-No, no, he's got -- his voice
has sustained beautifully.
So he's wonderful.
-And you're going back
on tour, as well?
-E Street Band.
-Coming back on the road.
-Unbelievable.
-February 1st.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-Now are you --
You know, I'm always --
every time I've been
lucky enough to see you live,
you know, I cannot believe
the energy
that goes into that show,
not just from you but
from the entire E Street Band.
When you have February 1st
in the future,
are you already
thinking about it?
Are you thinking like,
"We gotta get into show shape
right now"?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's, uh...
The thing with show shape is,
almost no matter what you do,
you are still going to wake up
the next morning
after that first show
feeling like you've been
beaten with a baseball bat.
[ Laughter ]
Every single thing
is going to hurt you.
Every muscle and bone
in your body,
your voice is going to feel like
it will never sing again.
And then you play
the second night,
"Eh, it's not so bad."
[ Laughter ]
-I got think you got to just
stick with it, right?
-Yeah, by the time
you're three or four nights in,
your body adapts,
and you get used to
being constantly tired
because you are.
And so I live with fatigue
for about a year and a half.
Your immune system drops,
so you gotta get used to getting
a little more regularly sick
just because of the --
to the degree that
you're pushing your body.
But it's still the greatest
[bleep] thing in the world.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I mean...
Obviously, it sounds like
you stayed busy
and you realized, you know,
there was an opportunity
with the pandemic
to do other things.
But I imagine from you,
the entire E Street Band,
from top to bottom, everybody
must be just so excited to be --
-Well, it's been --
we've been six years.
So it's a long time.
-Yeah.
-And, you know, I mean,
it takes us two seconds
to come back with each other.
But, yes, it's been --
we've been off for a long time,
so looking forward to it.
-We're gonna take a quick
commercial break, but I --
You don't know this, either,
but I do want
to tell you something.
One more thing about my mom,
which is we -- our first --
Not our first dance, but the
mother/son dance at our wedding,
she always wanted to do --
she wanted us to dance
to a Bruce Springsteen song.
-All right.
-And so the band
had to learn it,
and the song was "For You,"
from "Asbury" -- you know,
from your first album.
And my wife pointed out,
"That's a crazy song
that your mom wanted you
to sing a song where the lyrics
are, 'I came for you, for you.'"
She's like, "Why would you
do that on a day
where you're seriously here
for me?"
[ Laughter ]
She goes, "I think this is
a very aggressive song
for your mom to have picked."
-Now, get this.
I'm the guy that wrote it.
[ Laughter ]
So I know exactly what you're
talking about, you know?
[ Laughter ]
It's got -- you know,
it's a strange song.
I don't know what it means.
[ Laughter ]
It sounds suicidal to me.
But -- And it's a very unusual
song for the wedding...
-Yeah.
-...and the son/mother dance.
But, God bless.
-You know what?
[ Laughter ]
She thinks outside the box,
Bruce.
I don't know what to tell you.
I got more to ask.
We'll be right back
with more
from Bruce Springsteen.